- [Gary] You have to deal with
the reality of the situation.
Dwelling and
pondering and crying
doesn't do shit.
And it especially doesn't do
shit in this echo chamber.
In this arena,
there is no crying.
You can cry,
you're just gonna lose.
And I have bad news about
complaining and crying.
Let me tell you something
about complaining and crying
that's really, really gonna hurt
for all you
complainers out there.
Nobody gives a shit.
(audience applause)
And let me give you a
preview who gives a shit.
The following people give
a shit when you complain.
The other losers around you,
your sick broken parent
that secretly wants
to hold you down
so that you're not more
successful than them,
and let me remind
you one more time,
the other fucking
losers around you.